من غياه بالانقاذ والركام وبعد نحو 220
ساعات على الزلزال تتوالى المعجزات
سعيده لعالقين كتبت لهم الحياه من جديد
في ولايه هاتاي وفي اليوم التاسع من
الكارثه نجحت فرق الانقاذ التركيه في
انتشال شخصين على قيد الحياه وهما من اسره
واحده كانت عالقه تحت الانقاض من بين عده
اشخاص التقط المسعفون اهاتهم وهذه سيده
تركيه تدعى عائشه غول بايير في الخامسه
والثلاثين من العمر اخرجت من باطن الارض
حيه ترزق
قضت عائشه وخمسه ساعات تحت حطان منزلها
المهدم في ولايه كهرمان مراش مهمه شاقه
كللت بالنجاح بعد ان حفرت فرق الانقاذ
خندقا بطول خمسه امتار للوصول الى عائشه
ولان قصص نجاه العالقين هي ايضا قصص نجاح
المسعفين والمنقذين فهم لم يستطيعوا حبس
دموع الفرح
ومثل عائشه بضعه اخرون في مناطق متفرقه
في محافظه اديمان نجا الشاب محمد جيتين ذو
ثمانيه عشر عاما اذ اخرجه عمال الانقاذ
بعد ان ظل عالقا
199 ساعه كامله بينما يحدق محمد في ضوء
الشمس مجددا احاط به المسعفون قبل ان
ينقلوه الى المستشفى
وهنا في ولايه كهرمان مراش ايضا قصه نجاح
اخرى بل نجاح مزدوج حيث انتشل رجال
الانقاذ الشقيقين محمد انس يانينار 17 من
عمره وباقي نينار البالغه من العمر 21
عاما قال باقي انه ظل طوال الايام الماضيه
يشرب سائلا من مسحوق البروتين وهو مكمل
غذائي ساهم في ابقائه على قيد الحياه
هامش الامل يتضاءل ويتضائل لكن الاستثناء
يظل قائما خاصه لمن هم بصحه جيده وعلقوا
في جيوب امنه تحت الانقاض وبقربهم قليل من
الطعام والمياه